finlandia podría convertirse en el
miembro 31 de la otan impulsada por la
guerra en ucrania el gobierno finlandés
debatirá el ingreso a la alianza en el
parlamento así lo anunció la primera
ministra reiterando que la decisión se
conocerán semanas
hay diferentes perspectivas para
solicitar el ingreso en la otan o no
solicitarlo y tenemos que analizar todo
esto muy cuidadosamente como dijo
magdalena y tendremos esas discusiones
dentro del parlamento finlandés en las
próximas semanas white fast happening
weeks pero creo que nuestro proceso será
bastante rápido creo que tenemos que
tomar la decisión por nosotros mismos no
dejar que el miedo influya en nuestras
elecciones las calles de la capital
helsinki los ciudadanos están cada vez
más a favor de integrarse a la alianza
encuestas recientes muestran hasta un 68
por ciento de la población en pro pero
temen las posibles represalias de la
vecina rusia con quién finlandia
comparten 1300 kilómetros de frontera
y antes estaba en contra de entrar en la
otan pero hoy creo que es una opción
razonable de fair play si
definitivamente creo que rusia ha
mostrado su verdadera cara así que creo
que deberíamos entrar en la otan
suecia por su parte también está
sopesando una eventual adhesión el
pasado lunes el portavoz del kremlin
dmitri peskov advirtió a suecia y
finlandia que no se unieran a la otan
amenazando con que rusia tendría que
reequilibrar la situación con sus
propias medidas aunque el ministro de
defensa finlandés asegura que el país no
enfrenta a una amenaza militar inmediata
para los próximos cuatro años el
gobierno ha decidido aumentar el
presupuesto de defensa en un total de
aproximadamente 2.200 millones de euros
para este año además aumentaremos el
presupuesto de defensa en
aproximadamente 700 millones de euros
desde el final de la guerra fría tanto
finlandia como suecia se han mantenido
no alineadas profundizando los lazos con
la alianza atlántica pero sin ser
miembros